in may 1913 a bomb explosion ripped
through scotland's royal observatory in
edinburgh
a large earthenware jar packed with
gunpowder had been placed in the middle
story of the western telescope dome
next to an iron staircase it was
connected to a 30-foot fuse that had
been run down the staircase to the room
below
which housed the telescope chronograph
a clockwork device for timing
observations
the damage caused by the explosion was
extensive windows and doors had been
blown out plaster ceilings were
shattered
some of the staircase was blown off
splinters of glass were recovered 100
feet from the building
the heavy floor of the telescope room
directly above the bomb had been knocked
off the kobolds that supported it and
had been badly damaged
the driving clock which kept the
telescope fixed on a star while the
earth rotated was nearly destroyed
there was little doubt which group had
carried out the bombing that night
although the individuals involved were
never identified or caught
two notes were left at the scene the
first read from the beginning of the
world every stage of human progress has
been from scaffold to scaffold and from
stake to stake
the other said
how beggarly appears argument before
defiant deed
votes for women
this bombing was the work of
suffragettes and once again this was an
act of resistance against global
structures of power
carried out by those excluded from the
benefits of those structures